change wives he ought to be dr. lives
change organizations guy vs organization
might change the world
this is a picture of a flower right this
is a garden yes but to me they're much
much more why when I was a kid my mom
used to spend countless hours outside of
our suburban home in Fort Wayne Indiana
tending to her flower queendom she
wouldn't buzz around our silent suburban
home sprinkling little drops of love on
each of her Magnolia children like some
sort of Twilight Tinkerbell she was an
artist this is a picture of the street
in Kingston Jamaica my mother grew up
that's a ballerina bar where she spent a
lot of her life as well I was told she
was shy soft-spoken and self-conscious
in the streets of Jamaica I was also
told that she was an execution expert
determined and focused in the ballet
studio now I came to meet my mother
years later when she raised me in
forward Indiana when the execution
expert from the ballerina studios the
lover of flowers and the shy girl from
the streets of Kingston Jamaica all came
together in a beautiful mosaic that I
know and love this composite of a
personality it is my mother this is dad
odd calm pops this is a picture we took
last year down on the coast this is the
first time he'd been to California he's
from Memphis went to school in Atlanta
then went to work in Chicago raised me
in for when Indiana but here this was
his first time in the Pacific side of
the country and this is a regular
picture right no something different is
happening here to my dad how do I know
this a couple months after this trip I
said dad after that quiet road trip you
and I took how did you feel that day who
were you he hesitated as his way and he
said I was colorful
I was natural now I don't know if you've
met my dad these are not words used to
describe something so that got me to
thinking what is the role that plays
plays in shaping us in shaping our
personalities I thought some more and I
wondered how could I better yet how
could we think about how we could
investigate ourselves and unlock a new
dimension by thinking of the association
of place and personality so I let that
question and that idea marinate a little
bit and many epiphany started to bubble
up maybe a more holistic way to tell
your personal story your personal
history or maybe a new way to look at
spatial personality and emotional
landscapes ways to self explore and to
self explain so I thought about this and
I said let me explore this with my dad
let me talk to my dad so I said dad who
were you in Memphis he says oh I was
quiet I was timid I was very
mild-mannered you know Julian we played
the first interracial high school
football game there it was the all-black
high school my high school Douglas
versus an all-white high school in the
first quarter we were scared to tackle
each other well then what after that
then I went to Atlanta where I was at
Morehouse I was confident outspoken
inspired I was inspiring it's
fascinating and then well then I went to
Chicago in Chicago my father tells me
the hum of the city streets at that
perfect pitch made him feel flashy
vibrant and debonair now this exchange
of my dad was enjoyable of course but
more interestingly as I revisited the
conversation I realized something
special about my dad's perspective he
saw the world and his personality shifts
through race escapes
in Memphis he was quiet mild-mannered as
he alluded to by the reverberations of
the civil rights movement that he could
feel shaking through the classroom walls
and bubbling up through the football
fields in Atlanta he'd be inspired by
black professionals doctors lawyers
professors he became outspoken he found
his voice he found community in Chicago
he was a young professional flashy on
the streets and instead of defining the
city related to the Gold Coast he saw it
lined with inspired and motivated black
workers
this made me think i learned more about
my dad it unlocked the whole new doorway
into our relationship a whole new
understanding as I thought about this
understanding I thought about how can we
unlock the people we are based on the
places we've been how could we visually
represent who we are and our
personalities based on our emotional
experiences and I that it was a vision a
new map a new map to depict us where
we've been and who we are a new map that
can cradle the grandeur the magnitude
and the diversity of a life's journey in
a compelling visual icon me personally I
love Maps you don't have to but you
should reconsider why because we're
visual people admit that understand that
as humans we love stories and maps with
the beginning and ending points a room
for infinite story creation every day at
every turn every look maps tell us where
we are where we've been and if we're
lucky and paying attention where we've
changed in between this is a map by
Cameron booth it's a good design and
it's got a lot of acclaim recently why
some people say it's because he's taken
the confusing and winding topographical
reality of the US highway system and
replace it with the iconic vocabulary of
the London tube network it changes the
way we look at our world for me it's
good design because it changes the way I
tell a story it's immersive its
imaginative when I think about good maps
I remember walks in DC walks in New York
City good maps make me move through
space physically if they're
well-designed they help me get there
mentally but what about emotionally what
if you had a map to understand how your
husband felony is going through his
emotional Rocky Mountains you could help
them traverse those tough times or
navigate through them an emotional map
could help us unlock people in new ways
I have this hypothesis that place holds
the code to our personalities if we
understand people and how they are in
places you can unlock them in new ways
all I'm asking you today is to look at
people look at yourselves in a little
bit of a different way think about
representing a person based on the
places they've been if you look at
people experiences in a slightly
different way I think you could turn the
world on a 10 or at least rotate it just
enough to gain new insights so I engaged
in this exercise i sat down with a
friend cece she grew up in suburban
Chicago and I said tell me what suburban
Chicago was for you see see I was hoping
to unlock her personality through a
translation of that place she said oh oh
we had played bottle rockets I was the
youngest of four kids we play ghost in
the graveyard and I was always trying to
find my voice I was blond hair dye was
bubbly and I was spunky that's where I
became spunky I said CC could you tell
me in one image what that emotion was
like she said jumping on a trampoline
outside of my parents colonial home so
this is a crude rendering I did this I'm
no artist but after we sat down together
help me understand who CC was today my
friend the person I knew and that
bounding personality that she has comes
through in this trampoline image comes
through her finding her voice amongst
her brothers and sisters we explored
more and I said tell me more CC she said
later in life I went to Morocco as a
blond-haired girl I find myself in a
dark sook colored and covered and
surrounded by darker faces I was scared
I was really scared now in Morocco CC
didn't think about the steep grade of
the Atlas Mountains instead she thought
about the slopes of self-honesty she
said is it possible
maybe that I'm prejudiced that I've been
socialized in a certain way towards
other races now this was a monumentous
locational turning point for CC and
forever i think maybe just maybe self
honesty and self exploration will be
tied to that sucs and morocco and now by
understanding this and this picture i
know a little bit more about CC her code
of place her code of personality and the
person i'm friends with today you know
the interesting thing about this
exercise is that I got to sit down with
a couple of friends there's another
friend okay I learned numerous things
about her I learned how she is someone
who likes rules it likes being safe but
doesn't like feeling boxed in someone
who likes to plan she's a propensity for
planning but on many occasion has been
wooed by the sirens of serendipity
someone who had a good time finding
themselves in the east side of the
country but as tensions with cities like
New York because she suffers from the
tension between social stimulation and
the lack of solar infatuation and
someone k is someone who likes to feel
special for no apparent reason at all
this is a rendering I did after speaking
with K we had a long deep conversation
if she told me about her childhood and
suburban Detroit where she felt covered
in a bubble overshadowed by her over
sister and protected by suburbia she
then traveled to upstate New York where
her college was on a physical hill but
that came to represent a metaphorical
hill for climbing up her own mountain of
individuality and self-actualization she
then goes to New York where she dealt
with the bear and professional landscape
of new york and new jersey and she would
take wishful excursions to new york on
the weekends where she would deal with
that tension of a claustrophobic place
where memories faded too fast she said
Julian New York is always going to hold
this tension for me it's a place where
my friends and family I feel like I
should be but it always holds this
claustrophobic feeling and I can't shake
that and then we revisit brighter times
in LA we're on the plane ride there she
felt like a star just because
so as I thought about my interaction
with cash said three things and myself
one what next where do I go from here
could I help her recreate and keep
creating a map to tell her spatial
emotion trajectory through life as she
evolved can I give her an artifact a
calling card something to talk about
over dinner maybe a more colorful
myers-briggs I work with a local artist
and created this 4k so far it's a work
in progress but it's a story of her life
up to this point it helps me understand
how I know her and that's the second
point how I know k now I could be a
better friend to K why is that because
if we're heading towards a situation
that feels reminiscence of attentions of
New York City we could take an emotional
exit ramp at a place that reminds her of
the sunny times in LA and third I think
why not me why not us does this mapping
framework help us think about our lives
in a new way maybe I mean personally I
started do the non-trivial packing of my
life through this process I'm from
Indiana a boring state where I was in
the back of a minivan most of my life
trying to go somewhere trying to achieve
something and I guess I would cuz i go
to rhode island when i play college
soccer I lived through the soccer field
and develop the work ethic of a college
athlete that like this think I still
have today I spent a year in Africa
where I discovered my inner poet and
then I go and work in New York City
we're at once every day I was the
walking proof of accomplishment but the
vulnerability of lost imagination and
I'd rediscover that imagination in
Brazil where I found my cultural junkie
and today I'm here in California so I
ask yourselves who are you right now why
is it the musicians and artists of the
only ones that go to places for
inspiration and motivation why not
regular people why not be why not you
all I want you to do today is two things
or two words embrace place why because
it's important for yourself for your
personality development and for your
connections with people you love so I
thought about this when I started this
project that I wasn't sure where it was
going I said maybe maybe i'll create a
new with people to understand the
physical environment maybe they'll
understand landscapes will be more
specified for them I'm not sure I'm
there yet but maybe it's just an
imaginative exercise and maybe it's not
going to be a million dollar enterprise
but I'm encouraged because I think it's
a way for the self to be realized or
maybe it's just a way for me to get to
know my dad better or wait for you to
get to know you better I passed out some
sheets or my good friend katie has
passed out your machines with two maps
on each side I'm going to give you some
homework I want you to map out yourself
your personality trajectory over coffee
alone or with a friend over dinner and
tell me what you find call me if you
need help I'd love to help you get to
know you better and I'm sure I'd love to
get to know you myself as well thanks